[Music]
we all remember the help Tarkus gave us
that day Tarkus was like us someone
trying to make it through the world to
uncover the truth the least we can do is
follow in his footsteps and succeed
where he failed the knights of Beranek
are known for their heavy armor and
weaponry there is no nation that is
physically stronger but even among them
there was Tarkus a knight renowned for
having strength great enough to sport a
set of heavy black iron that was unique
to him alone Beranek was a land outside
of Lordran but it was not free from the
curse of the undead as the curse spread
and society crumbled countless nights
became undead but the Knights had not
lost their sanity yet throughout the
neighboring lands a prophecy was
spreading an old saying from astora that
said this thou who art undead art chosen
in thine exodus from the undead asylum
maketh pilgrimage to the land of ancient
Lords when thou ringeth the bell of
awakening the fate of the undead thou
shalt know the fate of the undead with
nothing else to go on
the undead Knights of Beranek ventured
to Lordran which was told to be at the
heart of the undead curse they were
right
the gods were partly responsible for the
crumbling world the light in Anor Londo
is an illusion and many gods have
already abandoned the world of men for
the real light the first flame was
fading there was one path into an
Orlando and that was through sins
fortress so the Knights of Beranek threw
themselves at the deadly castle trying
to force their way through and they were
not the only ones within sense fortress
we see the hollowed forms of both nights
of Beranek and Boulder two nations that
attempted to reach the land of the gods
desperate to discover the fate of the
undead near the top of sins fortress
there is an undead man who desperately
tries
to retain his sanity remember couch yeah
cow counts 1 1 2 3 4 4
voila 5 5 6 let me he has st. all the
heroes passed through sense fortress
never to return for a century they've
tried and failed the night king Rendell
blackened Tarkus and even logan himself
he won't stand a chance you'll be eaten
alive but go along if you wish if only
to deepen your despair they all failed
every night of Beranek every Bowl
tonight the night king Rendell and Logan
himself every one of them failed except
Tarkus Tarkus conquers the fortress
leaving his hollered brothers behind he
carves his summoning sign at the top of
sense fortress so his spirit will be
able to aid anyone else who comes as far
as he does time is convoluted in Lordran
and even if Tarkus is already dead his
spirit will remain to aid those who need
help with the final step even if those
heroes exists in another dimension for
guarding the final step to an Orlando is
the iron golem it is said that the soul
of this construct was originally the
bone of an everlasting dragon it has
slain countless heroes seeking an
Orlando for the sake of all those who
came before him Tarkus prevails he
becomes the first one to make it to an
Orlando but the tragedy begins here for
when Tarkus arrives at an Orlando he
finds the path retracted before him he
must break into the palace by the only
path available up a narrow ledge
through a window and across the ceiling
rafters protected by painting Guardians
this operation runs counter to his
skills encumbered by his armor and huge
weaponry Tarkas falls to his death on
the rafters and is dragged into a corner
by the painting guardians but his death
was not in vain because now the path is
clear and Tarkus helped you there for
the sake of the Fallen we carry on
[Music]
you